it appears that Robert Muller is at
least initially going to question Donald
Trump in the Russia investigation in
writing
meaning that Trump's lawyers will be
allowed to write totally innocuous
probably non perjury answers to
questions from Robert Muller if this is
all that is going to take place as far
as the questioning of Trump it's a total
disaster so this is according to sources
that are directly involved with the
process they told CBS News that this is
going on importantly we don't know
whether this is it for Trump's
involvement or if this is just step one
when CNN first reported it one of trumps
lawyers Jay Sekulow said no comment and
CNN said we don't know whether this is
the first of multiple rounds of
questions or if there's the possibility
of asking follow-up questions or if it
will culminate in an in-person interview
we just didn't know and it's been a huge
topic of contention for months now we
know that this rotating cast of lawyers
that Donald Trump has has been trying to
avoid Trump sitting down in person with
Robert Muller period and we knew that
they wanted written questions and
answers and at least based on the
current reporting there will be a round
of questions and answers in writing but
we don't know if this is a precursor to
the real interview or not Rudy Giuliani
says we are not prepared to agree to
more questions until this first group of
questions is asked answered and someone
can explain why that isn't enough
reasons why only written questions are
not sufficient includes that sort of
like with the FBI investigation of Brett
Kavanaugh was not sufficient because it
didn't even include questions to
Cavanaugh there is no opportunity to
explore whether Trump is telling the
whole truth if you just do written
questions write that phrase the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth it's easier to enforce that when
you can follow up with the person and
they're sitting right in front of you
because Trump's lawyers will likely
stick to the truth in their answers but
they're not going to volunteer the whole
truth and this is one of those cases
where the whole truth is really where
Trump could get messed up
and end up exposing the obstruction the
lies the possible criminality and the
most pressing question is why would
Muller allow this and there's a few
possibilities number one if Robert
Muller starts to think he's not going to
be able to get an in-person interview
that if he has to subpoena Trump that
the subpoena would be ignored or
challenged then maybe you say as Robert
Muller if this is all I can get I will
do some written questions that's one
possibility the more sort of clever or
devious explanation would be maybe
Muller is so well prepared that he's
hoping to get some lives or
contradictions in writing from Trump's
lawyers because they may not know what
Muller already has and getting lies in
writing would be much more powerful if
they are Trump's sworn statements then
the sort of subjective offhanded
comments that you might get during an
in-person interview but I'm thinking
like super optimistically here yeah I'm
leaning towards that second second
explanation because the Moller
investigation has been going on for well
over a year at this point so you have to
imagine they have quite a bit of
evidence and they know what went down
and you know maybe this is the best they
can get out of Trump because he is a
sitting president and he is so busy
after yes of course but tweeting about
horse-faced or me they could definitely
catch him in a lie or a few lies here
the truth is that if Trump did collude
with the Russians or obstruct justice or
whatever else he's probably lying to his
lawyers anyway so you may end up in a
situation where what Trump's lawyers
present to Muller are lies but they are
Trump's lies in other words his own
lawyers may not even know that those are
lies and Bob Woodward actually describes
a conversation between trumps lawyer
Jay Sekulow and the Muller team where
Jay Sekulow and maybe even John Dowd
also say we can't let Trump look like an
idiot because the transcripts will be
released other countries will realize
that Trump is a quote goddamn dumbbell
that's a quote and that type of thing
but I actually don't know that that's
really a concern in the sense that it's
a concern that other the other
leaders think Trump is a dumbbell but
they probably already know that if
they've dealt with him I don't know that
transcripts of an interview with Muller
would really it would really expose that
but to go back to Muller for a second
the most interesting theory I've seen
about why Muller would agree to written
answers for now is that he may not think
that he can legally subpoena Trump
successfully now and get him in the room
but if he gets written answers that
directly contradict what other witnesses
have said maybe that would give him
stronger legal justification for pushing
for the enforcement of a subpoena it's a
hypothesis I would just hope that these
questions are falsifiable right I hope
he's asking did you know about the Trump
Tower meeting ahead of time did you know
that Russia was trying to help and
influence your campaign because yeah
sure lawyers can kind of work their way
around that but in the end those are yes
or no questions and Mulder may already
have an evidence to confirm that those
are things Trump knew or talked about or
met with Dettol at the time what I think
is most likely to happen here is what
happened with Kavanagh I hate to be
pessimistic but it will be listen he
answered the questions there was nothing
obvious in the questions that justified
mandating or forcing an in-person
meeting and we're gonna have to continue
the investigation just on the basis of
these written answers that's what I
believe is the most likely outcome here
but I do want to hear from you about it
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
show was made possible in part by Scion
Games and their new game for phone and
tablet called antidote which is an award
winning strategy game it's all about
using vaccines to defend the human body
from bacteria and viruses it's fast
paced the graphics are amazing the game
has actually been commended by the World
Health Organization because it has a
mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram your
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video